[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur sensation
en association avec TV 78 en février
dernier le département des Yvelines a
organisé les assises de l'alimentation à
Thoiry pour en parler avec nous je suis
aujourd'hui avec Pauline vinocour
Lefebvre vice-présidente du département
des Yvelines délégués à la ruralité à
l'agriculture à l'alimentation et à les
circuits au circuits courts pardon
bonjour bonjour alors les assises de
l'alimentation ce sont donc tenus à
Thoiry en février dernier en quelques
mots 8 groupes d'experts étaient
mobilisés pour avancer sur 8 enjeux
prioritaires on va revenir un petit peu
sur ces enjeux dans quelques instants
pour le département pourquoi pardon le
département des Yvelines a décidé de
mettre en place ses assises de
l'alimentation alors elles se sont
lancées à Thoiry le 2 février c'était
pas leur réalisation puisque ça va durer
sur ça va s'étendre sur plusieurs mois
c'est un souhait du département
d'engager ces assises de l'alimentation
pour alors d'abord pour mieux répondre
aux objectifs qu'on s'est fixés en
matière de circuit court de produits
locaux dans les assiettes de nos
collégiens on fait déjà des choses mais
on voudrait mieux les faire et les faire
en soutenant encore mieux les filières
agricoles et
deuxième chose accompagner nos
agriculteurs pour qu'ils puissent
maintenir pour qu'ils puissent avoir des
fermes
dynamiques innovante et les plus
résilientes possibles dans un contexte
d'augmentation des coûts à la fois des
intrants et de l'énergie qui peuvent
fragiliser
certaines exploitations il y a donc une
volonté de modifier les habitudes des
consommateurs yvelinois pourtant de vers
une consommation plus plus locale et
plus respectueuse de l'environnement de
les modifier c'est-à-dire que le
consommateur fait ce qu'il veut c'est
lui qui choisit mais en tout cas de
faire savoir et d'activer tous les
leviers
que qu'un département est susceptible de
pouvoir activer pour rendre le produit
locaux les plus accessibles possibles
les circuits et les producteurs locaux
étaient en vogue pendant les différents
confinements que nous avons connu
pendant le covid-19 une sorte de mode
qui est rapidement passée après un
retour à la normale lors de ses assises
vous avez organisé des temps de
réflexion collectives sur différentes
thématiques ou plutôt des enjeux
prioritaires quels sont justement ces
enjeux prioritaires alors un des enjeux
c'est de se poser la question de la
fidélisation des consommateurs puisque
comme vous le dites la mode et la mode
est passée et c'est même retombée à un
niveau plus bas que ce que connaissait
les producteurs avant le covid pour de
multiples raisons donc il y a plus donc
8 thématiques
des réflexions sur les filières elle
vache fruits et légumes légumineuses
qu'on a séparé des fruits et légumes
c'est pas la même chose et sur les
logiques de territoire donc fidélisation
des consommateurs restauration en
circuit court résilience des fermes j'en
parlais tout à l'heure puisque c'est
peut-être des choses à faire pour
améliorer cette
résilience et rendre les fermes plus
plus performantes de ce point de vue là
et que ce soit plus tenable pour les
agriculteurs dans ce contexte si
particulier voilà à peu près les je sais
pas si j'ai fait le temps des 8 mais
j'en ai peut-être oublié une
et donc voilà les sujets sur lesquels
vont travailler les 8 groupes de travail
qui ont été mis en place de toute façon
au début notamment le
l'approvisionnement local dans les
restaurants scolaires ça on l'avait
évoqué les achats en local les enjeux de
la précarité alimentaire ou encore voilà
ou encore l'accompagnement la durabilité
et la viabilité
des fermes ce sont des enjeux à chaque
fois un tourner autour de de la de la
consommation des circuits courts
pourquoi est-ce que ces enjeux en tout
cas cette consommation c'est circuit
court c'est productions sont
essentielles au département
parce que
ce sont elles qui façonnent la ruralité
Yves linoise et la ruralité d'une façon
plus générale c'est l'activité agricole
qui est une activité économique qui fait
que nous avons les territoires que nous
connaissons et que nous aimons et il
nous semble important que ces
territoires puissent continuer à vivre
c'est à dire que quand on se promène sur
une route départementale qui traverse
des champs c'est pas juste un joli décor
bucolique c'est le travail d'un
agriculteur qui façonne ce paysage donc
sans élevage on a des friches sans
agriculteur on a des friches avec toutes
les risques tous les risques que peuvent
comporter les friches c'est pour ça
qu'il est essentiel de maintenir une
agriculture sur notre territoire et puis
à l'heure où se pose quand même la
question de notre autonomie alimentaire
c'est pas complètement déconnant de
se dire qu'il faut maintenir cette
activité sur nos territoires et que ça
part pas ailleurs huit experts étaient
présents pour échanger sur sur 8 sujets
quels étaient les rôles de ces experts
pour cette soirée
on a appelé ça des groupes experts la
soirée de lancement on a annoncé ce qui
allait se mettre en place et certains
agriculteurs et
acteurs
ayant lien avec les cirques courts sont
venus nous parler de leur expérience
mais les groupes de travail qu'on a
appelé group experts sont des groupes
dans lesquels on a réuni des personnes
d'horizon divers mais qui avait un lien
avec le sujet du groupe de travail je
pense par exemple au groupe fidélisation
des consommateurs auxquels on a associé
la grande distribution restauration
scolaire on y associer des parents
d'élèves puisqu'ils ont leur mot à dire
sur les menus qui sont proposés au
collégien notamment mais divers acteurs
de la restauration collective que ce
soit la structure qui
c'est midi la société qui chez nous gère
les les repas dans les cantines des des
distributeurs également parce que le
producteur il peut toujours produire de
quoi alimenter les collèges yvelinois
c'est pas lui qui va livrer les sans
cesse collège du département donc il y a
une problématique du dernier kilomètre
voilà donc au sein de ces groupes divers
acteurs
d'horizons très différents pour
voir sur quelle piste on pouvait se
lancer essayer de réfléchir et commencer
à imaginer les solutions qu'on pourrait
mettre en avant alors peut-être que sur
certaines thématiques il y aura pas de
solution ou en tout cas pas de solution
qui puisse être portée par une
collectivité comme la nôtre on
dit pas qu'on va tout résoudre d'un coup
de baguette magique on dit juste qu'on
va essayer de
de lancer des des pistes de réflexion
qui se concrétisons peut-être pas tout
de suite par l'annonce de mesure parce
que les assises doivent se conclure fin
mai ont tout sera peut-être pas prêt
mais au moins ça engage la réflexion
pour les mois qui suivront ce n'était
pas qu'une une soirée où vous échangiez
finalement c'est une soirée où après
enfin dans un communiqué de pièces vous
l'avez annoncé pendant 4 mois il y aura
des projets qui pourront être développés
autour de d'échanges et des découvertes
mais quels sont les enfin quel est le
programme finalement pour ces prochaines
semaines jusqu'à jusqu'à fin mai alors
si tout à fait ça c'était la soirée de
lancement et pour but de poser le le
thème et les objectifs et le pourquoi de
l'exercice on a eu il y a 15 jours les
premiers ateliers de travail donc les 8
groupes experts qui se sont réunis sur
toute la journée enfin quatre groupes le
matin Cannes groupe l'après-midi on a
travaillé sur des demi-journées pour
poser les axes de réflexion de chaque
groupe
voir sur quel parce que l'étape suivante
sont des visites de terrain
soit dans nos départements soit ailleurs
sur des projets qui peuvent avoir du
sens par rapport aux thématiques de
chaque groupe donc fixer ces rencontres
de terrain dans quelques semaines vont
se s'organiser ces rencontres de terrain
donc il y en aura au moins 8 mais on
s'interdit pas de visiter plusieurs
projets au sein de chaque groupe ça va
être riche et dense
et ensuite donc après c'est visités
reins qui se suivent donc l'idée c'est
visiter un le matin réunion de travail
l'après-midi pour continuer à réfléchir
à tout ça
dernier temps de réunion probablement à
distance puisqu'on a tous pris
l'habitude des visios et que ce sera
peut-être plus facile de mobiliser
notamment les agriculteurs une période
où ils sont quand même pas mal pris par
les travaux des champs avant la
restitution en mai au cours de laquelle
j'espère on aura des plus que des pistes
intéressante et pragmatiques en tant que
en tant que ancien habitant en campagne
en tout cas en dehors d'Île-de-France et
pour avoir échangé justement avec
plusieurs personnes l'Île-de-France
finalement une force insoupçonnée en
termes de de producteurs et
d'agriculteurs est-ce que ce projet n'a
pas aussi pour vocation de valoriser
justement les agriculteurs et les
producteurs de des Yvelines
à force insoupçonnée elle est pas
insoupçonnée pour les Yvelines noirs on
voit bien dans quel dans quel univers on
a la chance de vivre
oui bien sûr se pose la question la
visibilité de nos productions alors on
est une grande région de céréalières
essentiellement et c'est vrai que c'est
quelque chose de plus peut-être de plus
discret de moins on n'a pas un produit
phare yvelin alors je dis on n'a pas un
produit final c'est-à-dire qu'on n'a pas
un produit
identifié peut-être au niveau national
comme quelque chose de typiquement
yvelinois néanmoins on a quand même une
grande grande diversité de produits
locaux je pense qu'on peut je me suis on
peut complètement s'alimenter en restant
local on a même de l'eau minérale dans
les Yvelines donc on peut vraiment taux
de A à Z s'alimenter dans les Yvelines
et on a quand même quelques problèmes
quelques productions pardon tout à fait
emblématique on a la poule de Houdan la
salade de Montesson je me lance dans un
exercice péril parce que je vais en
oublier et je vais en vexer mais on a
des fromages des yaourts
et de grandes qualités en plus une
grande grande qualité de produits le
département des Yvelines est même nous
notamment faisons en sorte justement de
de faire connaître ces producteurs et
agriculteurs et les produits locaux
merci beaucoup Pauline vinocourt le
fervent d'avoir été avec nous sur
sensation pour plus d'informations on
peut se rendre sur le site yvelines.fr
et pour revoir ou réécouter cette
émission rendez-vous sur notre site et
notre application radio sensation
[Musique]